good morning bachelor nation welcome to
your Bachelorette recap this is roses
and roses a live and Dean Alert is here
a little round of applause for Dean in
our meager little studio here you guys
we have a new set and Dean you are
christening it so honored to be here
thank you so much for being here having
me we needed a big name to kick off
Becca Cooper ins big season you guys and
you had to settle on me look at Dean he
even he coordinated he was like let's
make sure that we really make this look
good so we are in black and I think that
the black symbolizes the ashes that we
shall all rise from like a phoenix
we are both eunuchs in this situation
I'm sure that you guys have questions
and comments for Dean and about Becca
season premiere last night thank you
again for tuning into ET live so leave
them on any of our social medias I will
get them right here and we're gonna dive
right in very quickly we have a comment
from Nicholas on YouTube and he says Joe
the grocer needs to be the next Bachelor
on his own show how could they have
gotten rid of him the first episode Joe
the grocer kind of went viral after last
night I feel like every season there's
one guy that goes home or one girl that
goes home on the first night and
everyone's like he deserves better he
deserves more at the end of day
Becca sent him home for a reason but I
do agree he's a pretty cool guy it seems
like maybe we loved his intro package
but maybe he just didn't make enough of
an impression on Becca I guess but still
it's like people are like lobbying like
like last on my season it was Blake like
Blake K for bachelor it's like okay like
he went home for a reason there has to
be something there member him now and
we're gonna forget Joe's name in two
days unless he goes on paradise with
Chris Harrison tweeted that he teased it
a little bit yeah Chris Harrison was
tweeting you know maybe we'll see Joe do
they have grocers in paradise and I say
yes I mean he was sweet there was a lot
of love for him from like even like
Ari's girls I think some other girls
that were going to paradise I think you
know someone's some people cut their
eyes on him do you know who's going to
paradise you know view are you going to
paradise are you you're so you're saying
you're out for this season of paradise
what about anymore reality TV for you
would you do it again in the future
no I well know bachelor shows okay there
are shows that I would like to be
that would be fine Wow amazing race
would be fun oh yes American Ninja
Warrior would be fine
who would you pick as your partner for
Amazing Race okay I've already tried I'm
already got some wheels in motion on
this but I want Ben Higgins and I to be
a team on The Amazing Race Oh that'd be
fun I feel like yes yes and you guys are
both pretty well-traveled I feel like
you jump into global international
travel pretty great
yeah so I like I look low-key dropped
the idea to Ben and he said he's on
board and I don't think he thinks I'm
taking it as seriously as I am but
you're like contacting I'm like reaching
out to Casting okay Ben and I want to be
on the next season get us on you guys
would be great on that because you're
both I feel like you have to be pretty
good with the flow for that show as well
like Nick vile might need some of his
grooming stuff with him which I think
Amazing Race would be almost more like
we want that instead of all right well
Dean for Amazing Race guys let's make it
happen
share bear on YouTube says do you think
Ari should watch Becca's season I would
love to hear your thoughts love you guys
love you share bear ari did tell et that
he might watch it so but that's an
interesting question do you think Ari
should watch it how do you think people
in bachelor nation feel about watching
their exes on TV later I don't think
many of them like it mm-hmm like if I I
don't I think he'll watch it I don't
know if he should watch it okay I feel
like he's kind of mentioned her Oh often
whether it's him or not like I don't
know if like people are asking him about
her and maybe that's part of it as well
but I feel like they're always gonna be
kind of like tied together so yeah well
if we want to show it we even had a
cardboard cutout yeah Ari last night on
the premiere you guys that's the thing
that stuff isn't it the reason Becca is
the Bachelorette is in part because she
is Ari's X so obviously we have to
acknowledge Ari and this guy went ahead
did it with a cardboard cutout it was so
bad was this bad why I hated this so
much tell me why it's just creepy you
don't want to she was engaged that guy
for like three months and now this guy's
bringing a cardboard cutout of him like
he could have at least like ripped it in
half or something in front of her if I
were Becca I appreciate Becca sent home
what was the guy's name Jake from
Minneapolis send him home she should
have sent the re cutout guy home the
second except I will know with it really
yeah set the tone set the precedent be
like no nonsense but don't you think
Becca is gonna bring up our
she has to she had just gone through it
all yeah but she's definitely tired of
it if you doesn't want to think about it
anymore by the way guys I'm sure you've
seen it a new interview that Ari did
with GQ magazine has gone pretty viral
because he said that he quote feels 100%
betrayed by the crew of The Bachelor he
is saying that his finale was in fact
edited even though Beca just told us
last week no no no it was as they said
unedited so all of that coverage is up
in et online.com right now including our
latest quotes from our interview with
Becca yeah I mean talk to us a little
bit Dean about production because Ari
said you know what you don't see is that
production was standing ten feet away
from me but to me hearing that that
wasn't a surprise to me like I assume of
course production and the crew people
around you absolutely yeah there's no
question at every moment of their entire
season they were ten feet away from him
because it's a reality show right that's
so I don't understand I it's kind of
weird that Beca saying one thing and
already saying something else well Ari
seems to have sick Ari seems to be
saying that in his mind it's edited
because you know production was saying
like go talk to her again and production
was nearby
but that wasn't shown on TV but to me I
again I assume with the reality show
yeah there are behind the scenes crew
people that you're not seeing in the
footage well I think even in that one
edited scene there showed like the sound
guys and the camera and all that kind of
stuff like when they were walking by
there was definitely I'm sure people
were telling Ari certain things but like
I don't see why they would have any
reason to edit that in you know well the
end of the day we all have free will
right don't do what you wanna do I don't
think I really want to relive that
finale because it was a bit of a cringe
thing so and well I know but isn't that
also where we were addicted to it a
little what was your thought should that
break up but it have been aired I do
think it should have been aired I agree
I don't think Beca would really well she
would still be Bachelorette but she
wouldn't have had as strong of a case to
be Bachelorette plus I think you know we
always people forget we always see the
break-up no matter what like this one
was a little more drawn-out different
but you always see somebody get dumped
in the finale right somebody who thinks
they are about to get engaged and
they've all signed up for that as well
like when you agree to do that show
you're agreeing to allow your life to be
filmed guys let us know what you think
of Artie's new interview larysa Ziegler
I say your name right Larissa says how
do you feel okay and what we answered
that was it too soon to remind Becca so
much of re so do you think that re
shouldn't have been brought up by any of
these guys at all I think that it was
bound to be brought up but if i were
stepping out of the limo again i would
not have brought it up at all yeah what
do you want your intro to be i would not
have made my entire amount of persons
act right yeah and that brings this like
down the line too when those two guys
were like you're here for the right
reasons or wrong reasons blah blah blah
it's like don't go talk to Becca for
your first time about something yes no
that was dark right I was I can't
believe they're bringing this to her on
night one one it was Chris and chase
bringing this he's not here for the
right reasons I texted a girl he dated
two years ago like oh my gosh we're also
connected at this point I was with chase
and Becca ended up sending him home tell
us if you guys think that she was right
on that I was with chase like I don't
know I I dated this girl a couple years
ago it's not really reflective of who I
am what did you think I don't know he
like brings the other guy over to like
sit down with them and then have like a
group powwow it was awkward
it was all together it was an
uninspiring first night in life did you
think overall for the premiere yeah
here's my thought I felt was it a little
tame yes I mean in the past we've had
drunk guys jump in the pool we've had
all kinds of stuff but did we need
something that was a bit of a palate
cleanser like did we need it to be kind
of even reset everything I guess no you
wanted more well we'll talk about the
season promo because that made me think
there will be more oh wow
Lauren Bastion on Facebook says will you
ever find love D that's not true
everyone will find love how are you how
are you I'm fine okay well let's just
knock it out cuz I know you know we
don't love to get into this but guys of
course our lovely Dean who by the way
runs an amazing podcast called how I
suck at dating did recently go through a
breakup so what happened with you and
Leslie um Leslie is a great girl we it's
just one of those things where sometimes
two people aren't meant to be together
and I think it was one of those things
to where it shouldn't have been it
neither of us wanted to drag it on
longer than we had to in the sense like
if this
isn't your forever person then you know
you should kind of nip it in the bud and
you know four months - and their
relationship is better than 12 months if
it's not going to mount like a marriage
and kids not kind of stuff but again I
still think the world fair I think she's
a great girl and I hope the best for her
yeah I mean I think you guys are two
great people and how did you you know
because a lot of people talk about when
you're on these reality shows you're in
like a bubble was it just getting out in
the real world and I feel like you guys
were kind of thrown into a lot because
you know you're both traveling and she
was kind of moving how did you figure
out okay we things were going wrong and
winter games but maybe this isn't the
forever thing there's definitely like
you kind of get taken back to earth
after the show where you have to realize
like what it's life like to live your
life outside of that kind of stuff and
you're not like spending every day in a
house with each other that wasn't really
an issue though like especially in the
beginning we definitely like made time
for each other and what kind of stuff
and I don't think we didn't make time
for each other later on it was just a
matter of I don't know just difference
of opinion on like just as people but
like I said she's a great girl we saw
each other at a wedding like two or
three weeks ago and things are perfectly
fine and amicable between the two of us
so we'll see we'll see yeah because she
lives in LA now I remember her telling
me at when her game she was moving to LA
so my roommate said he ran into her at
the grocery store that we shop at so I
guess she lives close enough to me and
Dennis okay so you're not talking all
the time but things are good oh we don't
talk at all but like I said we bumped
into each other and it was perfectly
fine like there wasn't a bad blood or
you thanked that which is great so yeah
of course that's right having been
through a couple TV romances and all
that you've kind of been through in the
past couple years has that helped you
figure out you know like Lauren says
will you ever find love what do you feel
like you are looking for here has that
helped you narrow oh it hasn't helped me
at all no it hasn't hurt at all it's
just it's adding a lot a new dynamic to
it that I have unfamiliar with that
we're all kind of unfamiliar with like
like a year ago before my season 1
episode 1 air whatever I could like make
a dumb decision or be an idiot and like
the only person has to deal with the
consequences are me and like the person
that I affected like whatever like a
friend or whatever it is and now it's
there's a million people that are like
Oh Dean's an idiot yeah I knew that I
was an idiot a year ago I'm gonna be an
idiot year from now as well and I was
just like a lot more public I guess you
know okay
so give one thing you've learned about
maybe what you're looking for in a
relationship I just keep working on my
communication I think like I my entire
life I've been very lucky introvert
inclusive and like just kind of like I
wanted like be like alone a lot of times
and like focus on myself
well not like focus on myself but but I
just like I understand the importance of
communication especially in today's day
and age when there's like a lot of like
rumor circulating or like I'll go
somewhere with a group of friends and
then people are like they're dating now
and like I had to like over communicate
like no like we're not dating like this
is just a friend you know does that mean
that you put it's almost sounding like
you put all the blame for your breakups
on your self kind of yeah absolutely
why well I think especially in this
situation like I'm the only one that's
able to speak on it so I think that the
only thing I can do is really blame
myself for the things I went wrong and
like I do have a lot of growth to do I'm
you know not that ages and excuse to 27
I think that I still have a lot of
discovery to do within myself before I'm
really ready for something like that
that's a hard thing to come to terms
with like you think you're ready for a
relationship at any time in your life
and then you slowly begin to realize
that you're not really necessarily as
ready as you thought and I've always
thought like no matter if you're ready
or not if the right person comes along
then that's when you'll be ready but I
think you know you need to kind of be at
a hundred percent before you were able
to welcome in another 100 percent sort
of think so okay that's where we're at
so you're taking all that blame on
that's a heavy burden but all the blame
on me and that's just been a cycle in my
life for the past nine months is I'm
happy to take the blame okay all right
well I feel like we have seen that
growth in you though I mean just you're
kind of reminded me of Ben Higgins a
little bit cuz he talked about how you
know you've got to take ownership in a
breakup and so this is growth you're
moving forward yeah yeah I guess help I
suck at dating as Dean's podcast help
him out guys Jessica on facebook says
Dean a lot of people are comparing Blake
to you how do you feel about the
comparison which one is Blake Blake was
roading on an ox pink jacket I just
really liked him that's good yeah I
don't know if I see that maybe just cuz
he's nice and peppy he definitely speaks
a lot more eloquently than I do
he doesn't stumble through his words
quite as much again so hard on yourself
bright and Mayer says
yes the guys referenced sorry way too
much during the night and Cindy on
facebook says Dean needs to be the next
Bachelor
well you said no more bachelor shows
what if you got offered bachelor itself
no I don't think so no I don't really
think so although I would like one of my
friends to be the bachelor who I don't
know like you feel like a Peter or I
don't know anyone that I know goes back
on Bachelor right and then I could cameo
like maybe a couple episodes that way I
could say that I was bachelor on
Bachelorette Paradise Winter Games and
bachelor checking all the boxes across
the franchise I love it okay also want
to ask you a little bit about okay so
yeah we had the guy who brought in re
the cardboard cutout we just saw Blake
Blake and Becca really seemed to have a
connection you know what I noticed she
was saying things about him like that
they were on the same wavelength that
they really got each other and I guess
it made me think about on this show they
always say follow your gut do you really
have to because you're not in like
normal situations with people so is
being on the show and figuring out who's
the right person for you a lot about
following your gut that's the thing with
Joe it's like they have grocery store
Joe the grocery store she spent two
minutes with these guys yeah and so all
you can do is follow your gut that's all
you got is that gun at least like
obviously like we have four five six you
have a better idea of who these people
are especially if you like your
one-on-ones and then eventually the
fantasy suites but for the first night
like these guys literally have four
minutes tops with her so yeah I think
all you can do is follow your gut all
you get even because we see them kind of
interact with her a little bit
throughout the night like all in all how
much time do you get with the lead on
night one so with Rachel I think we have
this remember like the Sandcastle thing
I think we were ladies sitting down in
front of sandbox for 90 seconds maybe
tops really and so it's like you and
then you get up there for the rose
ceremony you're like I don't know where
I fall in line with the rest of the guys
because I only had 90 seconds but every
other guy only had 90 seconds but there
as well because she's running around
doing interviews and like running from
spot to spot with all these guys and the
nice long but you still have 30 guys
that need to talk to her so gosh I think
all you have is your gut instinct okay
speaking of 30 guys I love how every
single premiere there's always the
discussion of how many more guys are
there gonna be how many were guys were
gonna get I'm like you guys have watched
the show it's always about 30 people why
is that a question okay people in the
room there's enough people here already
call it now ABC you don't have a number
of episodes you have to fill or anything
like that another standout from the
was Garrett's so we can show some of the
footage of Garrett getting the first
impression rose from her
he made an amazing entrance in a minivan
and she said she was smitten with
Garrett I was not impressed by Garrett
tell me why I don't know he kept he kept
saying one thing I can't remember what
it was but at the at the minivan he was
like he kept saying like that's cool or
something like that and I just rubbed me
the wrong way do you believe the minivan
thing was sincere he said I want to be a
good husband and dad I showed up in a
minivan I sure that sincere and I
actually do really respect so he was the
only one that like took her from her
spot as The Bachelor outside of the
mansion is like hey come over and except
really like I like made her meet him 50
social media participant guy what a move
he said you need to meet me 60/40 I was
not a fan of it I was glad she sent
Camille home but no I like that the mini
man thing was good I think Garret we
have a lot more to learn about him but
I'm not sold on him yet well there's a
little bit of controversy about Garrett
this morning did you hear about this I
am somewhat familiar with okay basically
some screenshots allegedly from an
account on Instagram allegedly run by
Garrett are showing him liking some
questionable memes and photos and again
it's not like this was a verified
Instagram account I think it's even now
been deleted so it's hard to tell was
this Garrett or not where did these
screenshots come from I guess I wanted
to ask you like what social media
directives are you given once you're on
the show or they told are you told like
be careful what you like or don't know
your own hero cuz on your season there
was some controversy with leandro past
tweets of his as well I think that
people just do a deep dive on your
social the second year like Castile's
get announced I remember you know it's
like like those like bustle or something
like wrote articles like Dean went to a
wedding three years ago with this girl
who is she and I'm sure like they do the
same like deep search of like things
that they like and all that kind of
stuff but so what he was like liking
he was seeming to like like really
controversial memes or posts about
different like policies and stuff it's
it's just we don't even really for sure
know if it was his again so it's hard to
tell I don't know there's definitely no
guidance well at least from our season
there was no guidance from ABC or Warner
that was like hey go through your
Instagram and your Twitter and scrub it
of everything that might be like I don't
know bad but
there's no like they're never like
posted this postal well they kind of
were like that for winter games a little
bit but I don't know are you given any
different advice like are you given any
advice advice before you go on the show
and then versus once filming is over
no none no okay I liked my Instagram was
weak cuz I only post like once every
couple months and then post show it's
like I guess I gotta start posting more
now but people like found out about like
I got like arrested a couple times as a
minor like for like a minor in
possession of alcohol and people were
like oh my god this guy's a criminal
people do like to make a big deal out of
things that aren't necessarily the
biggest deal I don't know again like
maybe what Garrett's doing but people
definitely like to build things up a
little bit more than they're they should
be I wondered because yeah I mean once
you're going on a show you would maybe
think okay maybe I should look at my own
Instagram and kind of go through but
it's hard to like there's we all put out
a lot of content that's hard to screw up
throw up especially like the things you
like like I can't go back and think I
mean granted all the pictures I like are
like puppies and all that kind of stuff
but not really room for controversy
they're big con fortunately but I did go
back and like I deleted to the pictures
of like me with my ex-girlfriend mostly
because like I didn't want people like
going to my profile and looking at her
and going to her profile and like
messaging her like that kind of stuff I
think that there should be like a
diligent scrub of things that you don't
want people to like I don't know it's
like fine but like just creep on you
know yeah because they can't get blown
out of proportion Cindy on facebook said
Garrett is trying too hard for her
interesting man Hanna from YouTube says
well Dean wouldn't need to be the
bachelor unless he pulled a nari and
came back years later I just mentioned
re
come on no more no more mentions okay
wanna go through a couple more things
with you so we had Garrett getting the
first impression rose
Becca said that she was really connected
to Blake who else were standouts for you
like who do you consider your
frontrunner at this point in terms of
who Becca will pick the only person
really that I like is Colton but do you
is it like you you liking versus who you
think Becca will like like you think
Becca's into Colton yes okay but Becca's
clearly in the garret as well mm-hmm but
my personal if I was a Bachelorette Oh
which maybe one day you're in the core
if you really want to get through all
the franchise's and calling the only one
that I know I've like I've got much with
Colton I met him a couple
I know that he's a great guy so maybe
that's only reason that I like okay like
this guy's nice well then can you
address what was told to us in the promo
which is that Colton says he's a virgin
but the other guys don't seem to believe
him yeah I think the other guys are a
little whack on that I've had a couple
conversations with Colton about that and
I think he's aware that that's gonna be
a storyline this season and I mean I
fully believe him I don't see why
there's any reason to think he's lying
it was kind of crazy that he said it and
they were I think it's Jordan the male
model who's like there's no way but I
mean I feel like that would be something
that would be pretty easy like if you
were lying about it an ex could just
come forward and say no it would be
pretty easy to disprove I don't know he
like says this or he mentioned this
thing to me the other day - he's like
whenever I got uncomfortable like I
giggle and so like you'll notice I'm
like I'm gonna get virgin like he kind
of give up a little bit it's not like a
joke he's just like that's his like
defense mechanism I mean I believe him I
don't see why not he seems like a great
guy he's like involved in nonprofits and
everyone that I've met that knows him as
well I spoke very highly of him so
Colton has your stamp of approval
he's the only one so far but again he's
the only one I met and Joe will give the
other stamp of approval even though no
one's met him for about 90 seconds
absolutely in September after paradise
then I'll give you another hot Joe yeah
okay so the promo did look pretty crazy
for the season we see Becca crying we
see Jordan this looks like a two-on-one
to me Jordans kind of going at somebody
Becca is crying and saying things like
he just did to me what Ari did so what
do you think of Jordan I don't mean
interrupt you but let's talk about it
I think Jordans giving us some good TV
so I don't have a problem with Jordan
right now I just I don't like it
I just funny because Nick so Nick and I
have did that recap thing and Nick loves
Jordan he's like every single every like
soundbite he has is hilarious yet Nick
vile and I'm like this guy just
everything he says it just just drives
me crazy for some reason but it is it's
all sound bites he's saying things like
I spent six hours hand-selected yeah I'm
being a male model is tasking you've got
to be I mean he's a sound machine it's a
reality show that's why I'm into it I
mean I guess we're that reason alone I
think we can safely assume he'll be
around for a while because he will be
giving us a buzz well I just I don't
know there's just so you felt like a
team premiere did the season promo
you hope for the season how'd you feel
about the promo I think it'll be
exciting it'll be fun to watch I think
it'll be better than bachelor right
the bar was pretty low from that one so
I think it's pretty safe to assume that
Jordan will be the main villain for this
season and like like you said Colton's
virgin storyline will be a main central
point as well but I'm excited to start
maybe liking more okay all right well
who do you think slayed in the premiere
and by Slade I mean like who had a great
entrance who made a good impression may
be other than Colton if anyone a great
entrance we had Garrett in the minivan
we had the choir the choir was good but
not the best not the best okay we have a
chicken suit guy no didn't like the
chickens in like who do you think is
quote not there for the right reasons
none of them were there for the right
reasons you just said you defend Colton
though no I'm just kidding Beck is there
for the right reasons I believe in Becca
I think that it's funny too because well
are we gonna criticize like the
decisions that she's makes like sending
Joe home on the first night picking
Garrett who potentially was liking these
controversial pictures on Instagram
whatever she is the one that knows these
guys better than any of us we get a
two-hour window to meet 30 guys so it's
like we don't know anything about them
like we glorify Joe even though we don't
know anything about him so I think
that's like the one thing that we have
to keep into consideration is Becca
knows what she's doing for yourself and
that's the only thing I don't think that
anybody can be there for the right
reasons anymore like you're going on a
reality show in the first place I have
no judgments on why people are there I
think you might be doing it for an
adventure you might be doing it for a
little bit of a career purpose I don't
know I'm over that phrase I love the
show but I'm over that phrase so what is
it what are the right reasons to you
just to go on TV and have fun I mean
Sean and Catherine Lowe were kind of the
franchise's golden couple both have said
they just went on the show to like maybe
see the world and meet some people now
they're in love and have two kids well I
think there's definitely a big appeal of
just a fun experience yeah like it's a
once in a lifetime thing that you
wouldn't be able to get otherwise so
that's a right reason and so are you
glad you went on The Bachelorette
yes I get asked that question and I kind
of waver on it like yes sometimes yes
sometimes not so much but I'm very
blessed to have been given an
opportunity to go on that show and it's
kind of led to a lot of amazing things
like sitting here next to you
but there have also been some drawbacks
what I think if anyone ever asked me
like do you think I should do it like
even my friends some of my growth
girlfriends are thinking about going on
the next season Bachelor applying or
whatever and I always say yes like do it
like it was an incredible experience
just like make sure you keep your wits
about you and make sure you act you know
authentically all that kind of stuff
which I felt like I did granted bad
decisions and all throughout the whole
you know ups and downs but it was a
great experience so I definitely think
it was a good so the act authentically
thing is interesting be on the heels of
re claiming this editing unedited thing
an editor and edited thing so do you
think that if you go on there and you
act authentically like who you are is
going to come across or is it possible
that do some people experience just
getting completely edited into something
else some people do but then there are
also people that think of themselves a
certain way and then they see themselves
playback on camera and it doesn't
coincide with what they think of
themselves even though it is but they're
just like that's not what I think of
myself so I'm gonna blame editing
because that's not who I am you know
I've seen like some people both from
like my season paradise and a little bit
of winter games where they were like
blaming editing and like like I had an
issue with editing a little bit on
paradise just likes it maybe blew it up
a little bit more than it was but at the
same time I was still doing all those
things and saying all those things so
it's like they can't really edit it to
alter everything that you're saying and
doing you know so yeah I mean I think if
you're a good person you go there with
the mindset of just to like be friendly
and see what could potentially happen
then don't really anything to worry
about
okay I like that a rude awakening of who
you might be presented to you via
reality television and it's alright I
mean it's hard to see if I'm like a
third party perspective because
especially a lot of these guys like I
would say 98% of them I've never seen
themselves on television before and then
you see yourself on television it's just
the perspective that you're not used to
seeing yourself in like a new light and
so it's like that's not right because
that's not who I thought I was even
though it is interesting I like this
insight again his podcast is called help
I said Jessica via Facebook says she
cannot deal he reminds me of Blake II
and Rob who's Jessica talking about I
think we're missing a neighbor he's
talking about me no I think she's maybe
talking about here maybe Jordan he
reminds me of yeah Blake II and Robbie
me there's a couple things on Twitter
last night that was like my Robbie haze
plus my picture equals Jordan or some
things that interesting
with some not so kind words the captions
like doosh 1 + douche - I don't know if
I can say douche but I said it three
times so I would not agree with that I
did think it was funny that Camille was
dubbed social media participant because
that was even a step down remember on
Paradise Robbie was social-media
influencer so now we've gone down to
participant now we're just bringing in
the party yes oh yes the model Jordan is
yeah Jessica can't deal with him Wow I
think you're right that he might be a
little bit of a villain what do you
think about um it seems like from the
promo Lincoln might become a villain
which surprised me because he's been
like such a nice guy it was the somebody
was saying he's a pathological liar
I don't know that accents really
throwing a sock okay cool so okay cool
do you like Colton you don't like
anybody else not yet not yet who do you
think you can grow to like um oh wow
he's just a Colton fan Colton if you're
watching Deen is just clay seems like a
big teddy bear he seems very sweet he
does seem very sweet I think sometimes
good guys that are too nice get a little
lost
it's good clay gives me remember Matt
from my season mm-hmm Matt was one of
the nicest guys I've ever met my entire
life very soft-spoken and clay and the
very family-oriented and Claire reminds
me very much of that and I think
everyone from my season will agree that
Matt's one of the nicest guys that we
ever met and so I'm sure clay in the
house there's like very you know looked
very highly upon and like everyone likes
him I don't know if that really
translates well to this environment
because you have to be a little more
outspoken and like be willing to like
fight for time and all that kind of
stuff but I like him he seems like a
nice guy okay okay
so I hope I suck at dating does that
mean you're single right now are you
still sucking at dating I'm still seeing
a baby
there was a brief stint where I didn't
suck at dating for a while and now okay
I think I saw a quote from you said you
were single AF so that's still the case
not my words it was Oh Marc one of the
producers was like would you say it's
safe to call yourself single AF and I
said yes I can call off by myself the
same way yes after your less than I
broke up I have realized that I'm gonna
take some time for mice
I've been going it therapy which has
been very helpful I just need to spend
some time being more like that's the
thing too is I always thought that I
knew what I wanted in a relationship and
then I like to realize that I wanted
different things in a relationship and
it's just not really fair for me to
bring someone into a relationship when
I'm still uncertain 100% of like what I
need to be in happy in a relationship so
we'll see what I like it's always gonna
take time for yourself so a therapy does
that mean like traveling what do you see
is the next few months for you what do
you mean so like what well taking time
for yourself is that like just focusing
on your job is that sticking around here
in California it seems we're not gonna
see you on paradise so what is your
summer look like what is taking time for
yourself entail I've got involved in
like some nonprofit organizations around
LA it's like help me keep my mind
occupied I've been like reading
meditating the therapy has been helpful
because I've never really had like an
unbiased resource to just like go and
talk to and like hit be like hey what do
you think of this how should I react to
this like why does my brain works this
way etc etc beyond that I have been like
just pursuing different I guess hobbies
or interests so like I've been like
working on getting like a pilot's
license I've been hearing things where
it's like I've always wanted to do these
things so now I'm going to like do them
because if you need to you know you know
you want to continue to figure out what
I'm interested in so awesome and
spending a lot of time with some friends
that you've made through the franchise
you and Jarrod and Mick are doing some
really funny recaps of bachelor are you
gonna continue that all season long yeah
so what Nick is calling it is the bad
chiller which I guess if you say it
quickly just sound like bachelor you
know yeah yeah we're gonna recap every
episode we're gonna hopefully have you
on one of these episodes I love it as
long as I get to wear a wig you guys I
mean we're doing those wigs yes we have
at least two dozen wigs so that's pretty
fun it's it's just kind of like a silly
thing that we decided to do mm-hmm I
don't know why but it's fun so yeah and
we're figuring things out Wendy on
Facebook says what about Ashley and
Jared well what about them they seem
very happy Wendy they're so in love with
each other yeah yeah I'm actually going
to meet Jared at the podcast after this
and I'm going
grill the heck out of him about what his
life is like now that their open
relationship
yeah well publicly open relationship
right how does that work I'm super happy
for them like obviously I had been
friends with Ashley for a while so I
knew her feelings towards Jared and we
obviously saw it through like paradise
all that kind of stuff and Jared and i's
friendship is a little bit newer but
ever since even him and i first met like
six months ago he always spoke very
highly of her so it's nice to kind of
like finally see them like come together
and be able to just love each other love
isn't love great when it comes out of
this franchise it's just so wonderful
okay you guys we are gonna wrap down
here because you know Dean's got to go
films podcast so check it out and thank
you so much for watching with us we will
have a new episode of roses and Rose a
that's highly focused on every single
minutia of last night's premiere up this
afternoon and every Tuesday morning
we'll be here recapping the Bachelorette
so thank you again for tuning in and you
know we're gonna try not to say let's do
the damn thing and try not to mention
Arie and just love and support Becca and
her season whoa thanks for being here d
thanks for having me have a great day
everybody bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you